Попри закон про державне фінансування українських політичних партій,
їхні виборчі фонди досі часто наповнюються нелегально.
Такого висновку дійшли у громадському русі "Чесно".
Закон вимагає  від партії оприлюднювати  фінансову звітність,
але, як показує аналіз громадських активістів,
значно охочіше партії вигадують різноманітні схеми
отримання коштів через посередників.
Ось найбільш уживані схеми та найдивовижніші обхідні шляхи,
щоб наповнити партійну касу в Україні.
Часто свої гроші сумнівного походження
партії легалізують оформленням у формі пожертв від пересічних громадян.
Журналісти програми "Схеми" з'ясували:
"Батьківщина" Юлії Тимошенко лише минулоріч
протягом 8 місяців отримала від простих українців
близько 150 мільйонів гривень.
Люди несли гроші цілими родинами.
Серед донорів були пенсіонери, студенти та безробітні.
Окрім того, формально добровільні внески на користь "Батьківщини"
відбувалися синхронно й організовано.
Найчастіше жертвували по 15 і 150 тисяч гривень.
Найбільше питань викликають партії,
чиї надходження від пересічних громадян стрімко зростають
у той час, як їхні рейтинги падають.
Так, зокрема, відбувається з "Самопоміччю" та Радикальною партією Олега Ляшка.
Попри втрату популярності серед виборців,
цьогоріч за перший квартал вони назбирали
15 мільйонів і 109 мільйонів гривень відповідно -
формально від приватних осіб.
Окрім того, часто самі ж партійні представники
в регіонах фінансують рідну партію.
За даними руху "Чесно", понад 90 штатних співробітників Радикальної партії,
яку отримують мінімальну зарплату,
профінансували свого роботодавця на 9 мільйонів 300 тисяч гривень.
Ба більше. Деякі з них переказали на партійні рахунки
значно більше грошей, ніж узагалі заробили.
Окрім того, значна частина донорів партії
не має жодного бізнесу, але підтримують улюблену партію сотнями тисяч гривень.
Подекуди значні кошти на рахунки партій
переказують фірми-одноденки. Зокрема,
журналісти програми "Наші гроші" виявили, що
фіктивна фірма пожертвувала "Опозиційному блоку" мільйон гривень.
Пізніше з'ясувалося: засновниця фірми -
продавчиня в магазині, яка передала свої паспортні дані невідомим,
а ті зареєстрували на її ім'я кілька фірм.
Сама ж вона жодних партійних пожертв не робила.
Популярний спосіб наповнити чорні партійні каси -
створити однойменні громадські організації
та збирати кошти на їхні рахунки.
Такі організації часто використовують такий самий сайт,
ті ж сторінки в соцмережах, таке ж візуальне брендування, що й партія.
Вони також агітують за партію і здебільшого оплачують їй рекламу.
Перевага полягає в тому, що такі громадські організації
не зобов’язані, на відміну від партій,
звітувати НАЗК про джерела походження коштів.
І зовсім простий спосіб нелегального партійного фінансування -
просто не вносити у свої звіти цілі напрямки видатків.
Як вважають у Комітеті виборців України,
значна частина виборчих кампаній оплачується нелегально - просто готівкою.
Наприклад, на оплату роботи спостерігачів,
агітаторів, представників у виборчих комісіях або на нелегальну рекламу.
Фінансувати все це чорною готівкою значно простіше,
щоби згодом нічого не пояснювати про джерела надходжень.
Попри наявність непрозорих схем,
у Комітеті виборців України відзначають і певні поліпшення
після того, як три роки тому запровадили державне фінансування партій.
Зокрема, політсили почали офіційно платити заробітну плату,
легально рекламуватися в ЗМІ тощо.
Цьогоріч шести парламентським партіям
держава виділить загалом більше пів мільярда гривень.
Цих грошей, як вважають у КВУ, має бути цілком достатньо
для незалежного партійного життя,
відмови від коштів олігархів і чорних кас.